on dirait que je vois des points
d'interrogation un peu nos visages
souvent posé la question pourquoi je
vous parle et demi de coin
pourquoi je ne parlais d'une monnaie
qu'on ne peut ne même pas touché
rassurez vous aujourd'hui moi je vous
parlais de la raison qui donne une
vision où l'on sent la fin il s'avère
que c'est la même vision et qui motive
d'autres entrepreneurs que moi et des
développeurs à travailler ensemble et
faire du big wave possiblement la plus
grande évolution par internet
alors quelle est cette raison qu'est ce
qui fait à la fois réagir les
détracteurs et les adeptes de 8 points
eh bien c'est la possibilité ou même
l'éventualité d'un monde décentralisée
c'est de ce qu'il est question et puis
ce concept 1 vient perturber notre cadre
de référence pourquoi parce que en fait
on n'est pas dans un monde décentralisée
notre univers
il est centralisé alors il ya quatre
thèmes très important pour un système
décentralisé puisse fonctionner et puis
le bitcoin qu'on le regarde
vous avez si une monnaie que vous permet
de faire des transferts d'argent d'une
personne à une autre de manière
instantanée sans avoir à demander
permission préalable sans aucune limite
quant aux montants transférés puis tout
ça des frais pratiquement neuf et c'est
possible pourquoi parce que au lieu que
cette monnaie soit contrôlée par des
banques et des gouvernements
mais l'information en fond si gérés par
des milliers d'ordinateurs à travers le
monde qui s'échangent et l'information
de manière peu et ou pire donc c'est
comme grand agissent comptable et enfin
mon avis depuis sept ans le bit coin
c'est une expérimentation pour nous
démontrer qu'un système décentralisé via
parce qu'il répond à ces quatre thèmes
l'accessibilité la liberté la protection
la vie privée et la transparence donc
parler un peu de moi c'était moi en
afrique en 1994
donc moi je suis un québécois d'origine
du rwanda ma famille et moi nous étions
au pays
et puis donc c'était au moment de la
guerre et vous pouvez l'imaginer c'était
le chaos total
et à ce moment là des banques
omer c'est plus rien qui est accessible
et donc mes parents de vérifier sur le
peu d'argent de poche qu'ils avaient sur
eux et cet argent là ils ont dû le
cachet pour franchir la frontière parce
qu'évidemment les milices c'est sauve
qui peut c'est la loi de l'argent
commenté
et donc ils y ont dû cacher cet argent
dans les bons mon père est aussi dans la
couche de ma petite soeur qui était né
deux mois plus tôt et la raison pour
laquelle on fait ça évidemment je ne
l'expliqué mais heureusement on est en
mesure de franchir la frontière sans
problème et puis donc que les miens sont
pas pu découvrir l'argent qui était
caché son jeu raconte cette anecdote
parce que j'ai remarqué un coeur dans
les moments de crise dans les moments
d'instabilité
y'a rien qui garantit puis vous avez
beau être une célébrité quelqu'un
d'important
un ministre un ministre de l'intérieur
comme on dit mais on ne pouvait pas
garantir à 100% la propriété de vos
enfants puis ça c'est une situation à
qu'on retrouve actuellement un peu
partout dans le monde vous fait penser à
ce qui se passe en grèce en syrie ou à
chypre a observé il ya deux ans ce pays
neuf et est au bord de la faillite
et puis il y eut des lois draconiennes
qui ont été votées qui ont imposé aux
gens des taxes extraordinaires sur leur
compte à la banque est aussi belle
audace qui pouvait rien y faire il y
avait même des limites de transaction
donc vraiment l'accessibilité c'est l'un
des thèmes les plus importants qui m'a
attiré vers le big one comme tant
d'autres parce qu' il ya tout son sens
et permet aux gens dans des situations
de crise de garder le contrôle de
l'argent est aussi de pouvoir y accéder
en tout temps l'autre terme concerne la
liberté quand on regarde les sites wap
arbitres coin il y en a une qui ressort
souvent c'est celle concernant wikileaks
car en 2010 wikileaks a fait face un
blocage internationale que c'est à la
suite des divulgations de plusieurs
secret des temps sur les politiques
étrangères des pays occidentaux
quoi qu'il en soit on fait face comme
jeudi le journaux mais y'a pus droit
aucun financement
là vous avez des gens de la communauté
pied de coin qui on proposait avec leeds
accepter les bons les dons envie de coin
pourquoi pas en dieu
et puis quand on regarde sur l'adresse
qui est disponible sur internet donc
tout le monde allait vérifier toutes les
transactions
c'est transparent pouvoir toutes les
entrées sorties on voit que c'est près
de 1.9 millions de dollars
ce stand
quand envoyés par des gens comme vous et
moi qui ont été sensibilisés par la
cause de wikileaks donc lui plusieurs
manières de voir ça moi la manière je le
vois c'est que vous avez ici des gens
qu'il y aurait pu aller voter à
protester dans la rue mais au lieu de ça
ils ont utilisé une technologie donc un
autre venu pacifique pour exprimer leur
liberté d'expression
et puis cet exemple de lucky luke ce
mano troisième thème qui la transparence
donc on s'est un fait très difficile
pour le simple citoyen de venir auditer
les chiffres qui nous ont faire tout les
chiffres d'ordre public où toutes les
données tout ce qu'on nous dit à la télé
c'est difficile de venir l'audit et et
puis l'exemple de wikileaks nous
démontre qu'il est possible de voir en
temps réel les transactions qu'ils ont
eu envie de coin des devoirs restions à
louer cet argent donc maintenant
imaginez vous un monde idéal où que mais
on va être capable de voir notre donc
qu'on ait fait oeuvre de charité
combien d'années pour des frais
d'administration ou combien d'années
pour exposer écoles qui étaient
construites en afrique par exemple ou
encore mieux on pouvoir demander ou
exigeant gouvernement qui nous montre
notre argent ou ce qui va c'est quoi les
contrats publics sont signés tout ça est
possible d'une manière sans que les gens
aient à se casser la tête pour le faire
et le dernier terme et non le moindre
c'est la protection de la vie privée
depuis 20 ans cette liberté de pouvoir
communiquer entre nous via internet mais
malheureusement on voit que cette
liberté a un prix à payer
là je vous parle des révélations de
snowdon cet ancien agent de la national
security agency qui me faire de
révélations ces troublantes sur les
programmes d'espionnage et aussi à
toutes ces applications caché qu'ils
viennent connecter nos données dans les
nouveaux appareils mobiles et puis c'est
là que le béton et le bit coin n'amène
de l'espoir pourquoi pas cette
technologie nous permet maintenant de
transférer de l'argent sans se soucier
que nos informations bancaires qui sont
sensibles puissent être interceptées et
ses capacités à commence de plus en plus
être répliqué pour le message texte
nos photos nos vidéos bref tout souvenir
qu'on veut c'est changer l'internet ont
commencé à utiliser la même technologie
donc de crypter nous donnait alors comme
j'ai dit tantôt il 4
thème très important que système
décentralisé puisse fonctionner et puis
depuis sept ans vraiment la vie de
pointe à mon avis une expérimentation
pour démontrer qu'un système
décentralisé via et puis on va se dire
je parle beaucoup du bien mais on
s'entend que si c'est bon pour le bien
il ya des gens aussi qui vont utiliser
pour le mâle faut pas se le cacher mais
l'important c'est que l'argent c'est le
nerf de la guerre
ainsi l'instat yves qu'on retrouve dans
chaque système chaque domaine puis on a
été en mesure d'enlever de ce contrôle
des banques et des gouvernements ce qui
à mon avis l'élément le plus difficile
on est en train de faire a que 8 points
maintenant pouvons-nous répliqué ce
domaine et l'appliquer à d'autres en
fait pouvons-nous répliqué ce modèle et
l'appliquer à d'autres domaines afin
qu'ils soient plus transparents plus
accessible et où les gens vont être
libre c'est de ce que les questions et
c'est pour ça aussi que ça va au delà de
8 kw et que ça va dans les autres
directions car que ces technologies
soient accusés massivement non ça n'a
plus vraiment d'importance
juste le fait qu'il existe une demande
de nous réinventer et d'innover dans
nous vient manière de faire cela pour un
entrepreneur comme moi là c'est une
raison qui devenu une vision pour
mercenariat
ainsi ce qui explique aussi pourquoi
j'avais d'autres entrepreneurs comme moi
qui prenne autant de risques pour se
lancer dans de nouveaux modèles
d'affaires qui faisait pas auparavant
et pourquoi vous avez des développeurs
la grande majorité sont jamais
rencontrés ce qu'un espoir mais ils
travaillent ensemble pour améliorer
celui ci libre et en fer possiblement la
plus grande révolution emprunteurs nets
merci